anybody being duped by Simpsons paradox
before or yeah it hurts definitely hurts
so we're going to talk a bit about some
statistical tests and algorithms that we
produce - just to find occurrences of
Simpsons paradox and data so I'm just
going to talk a bit about what Simpsons
paradox is and the algorithms that we
use to detect Simpsons paradox and and
NASA name is gonna give a live demo of
some github code that we have for
looking for cases of Simpsons paradox in
data okay so can you trust the trend do
you want to be duped by your data so um
okay so I'm a stock exchange question
answerer
and so I log on to stock exchange at a
p.m. and I start answering some
questions one at a time so um do my
questions get better as an answer them
or do they get worse or do they stay
about the same and here when I say
better I mean um the probability that
they'll be accepted as the best answer
so who thinks my questions get better
over time
as I answer more questions okay some
people who thinks they get worse then
maybe I get fatigued worse okay yeah
okay so on average questions get better
as Y so here on the x-axis we have
answer position within a session and
here under y-axis we have acceptance
probability so actually the trend is
increasing so basically as you go on
throughout your session your answers get
better okay another example so look at
Redis so as people spend more time on
Reddit so let's just say there they sign
up and then they're on writer for a year
two years do do reddit users get more
active over time or less active hootings
to get more active over time okay one
who thinks they get less active okay
more people okay they get more on
average reddit users get more active
over time so the question is can we
trust these trends these univariate
trends and the aim of our algorithm
really is to to see if these trends are
true of Earth there's some confounding
factors that basically call us the
trends to appear as they are I mean and
I guess as data scientists we all know
that we see a result and we say oh we
can explain this by our okay this is
counter and
here's an explanation we can kind of
explain anything so um I guess getting
to the roots of the Simpsons paradox is
a kind of a better way of finding true
patterns within the data so what is
Simpsons paradox oh so since this
paradox is basically a trend um when a
trend appears different in subgroups and
then it disappears or reverses when we
aggregate so here if we look at the
Simpsons family as each subgroup so we
can see that we have some downward trend
but then when we aggregate over every
member of the subgroups every member of
the family that the trend is actually
increasing so so at the lower level we
have some relationship which is
decreasing but just purely by aggregate
aggregating this trend reverses so that
this aggregate trend is obviously
something that that can be misleading
and lead to miss conclusions and and as
such is quite dangerous for data
analysis so an illustration so do
smokers live longer so here is a study
it was actually from a stats blog so
looking at mortality rates for smokers
versus non-smokers so so actually
smokers have lower mortality rates than
non-smokers which I guess is a
surprising conclusion but let's look at
each age group so here's different age
group for smokers and we can see that
within each age group smokers which is
the blue line actually as higher
mortality rates even though on the
aggregate they have lower mortality
rates so what's going on here and and
basically it's a it's a it's an effect
caused by the way the data is
distributed within the subgroups so here
let's look at how the percentage of
populations for smokers on the Left
versus non-smokers for each age bracket
so we can see that here for the smokers
only 8% are over the age of 65 whereas
27 for the non-smokers are over the age
of 65 and I guess mortality rates are
generally higher for for people who
for older people so that the higher
waiting towards older age groups causes
the data on the aggregates to to become
larger the mortality rates so for
example when we are calculating the
mortality rate for for a nonsmoker we
multiply the mortality rate for this age
group which is quite high seventy five
by nine percent and and this other high
one by 18 percent whereas for the
smokers we're only multiplying the high
by two percent and the second highest
one by six percent so so the trend is
clearly reversed so even though smokers
at the individual level are have higher
mortality rates when we aggregate them
the reverse trend is shown so here's an
example from tala
M where I work currently which is so
Tyler gives credit and based on
alternative data points and
non-financial data points so we use
people's behavioural data from their
mobile devices to predict repayment and
and to kind of create credit scores and
one of our competitors branch found a
kind of counterintuitive results that
that actually people who gamble more
have higher payment rates so I guess you
could think that's maybe a bit
counterintuitive people who spend more
money gambling actually repay loans at a
better rate and indeed actually looking
at our data we got the same results so
so on the x-axis here we have gambling
spend and under y-axis we have repayment
rates so people who gamble more get
repay our loans actually a higher rate
but there's a confounding factor here
which is time so generally people with
older devices or who have more data or
data going back further actually a
higher payment rates and the more data
they have the more information we have
on gambling habits so that actually when
we look at gambling spend per day the
trend reverses actually people who
gamble more per day have lower payment
rates so another occurrence of the
Simpsons paradox within our data okay
it's all very interesting and now I'd
like to talk just about the methods and
are the algorithm that we use to detect
paradox within data so yes so we develop
algorithms to systematically identify
Simpsons paradox so basically we give in
a matrix with some response variable and
lots of predictor variables and then our
algorithm returns pairs of Simpsons
paradox payers ie there's a trend with
one feature that reverses when we
condition on another feature so for
example a trend on gambling that
reverses when we condition on time so
how does it work so for each covariate
for example I talked earlier about stock
exchange and answer position we
basically estimate the trend and the
outcome variable which is accepts in
probability with respect to the variable
in this example here we just use a
linear model a logistic regression model
to fit the trend and we get some
coefficient linear coefficient which we
can see is it statistically
significantly increasing is it zero or
is it decreasing then we look at the
auto covariance and we disaggregate the
data so here for example we're looking
at session length for answer position so
actually how many people how many
answers did somebody perform within a
single session so earlier we looked at
answer position and now we're saying
actually how many answers were there so
here you can see in the table the
majority of people who use stock
exchange just answer one question
some used answer two questions and it
kind of tails off pretty quickly and
then for each of these subgroups we fit
another logistic order linear models so
for example for people with session
linked 1 then there can only be one
answered position because they only
answered one question for people with
session link tutors to the you know
their first question and their second
question for people who answered three
questions session link tree there's a
tree data points so the first answer
second or third answer and and we see
here that the trend reverses so actually
your intuition was correct that actually
as you answer more questions the
exceptions probably decreases so your
to somehow become worse but when
aggregated over over all of the
subgroups we get the other trend so
basically - yet to conclude just about
the method so we fit a model to the
covariate and then we disaggregate to go
variate or sorry the confounding feature
and within each subgroup we fit we fit
linear models and then we compare the
trends we compare the slopes to see if
there's reverse behavior okay so
disaggregation that's cool for the the
the number of sessions because it's got
low cardinality there's very few actual
number of session lengths but what about
some more continuous high cardinality
features for example the number of
answers that somebody's ever answered on
Stack Exchange which goes from 1 to you
know 10,000 so we can't look at each
number fit a regression model there
because we have very few data points for
subgroups so I guess the question is how
do we disaggregate um if we have
continuous variables and the solution
for us what's the basic fit 'try so so
here we look at an answer position again
and acceptance probability and we see
this trend and here then is the feature
number of answers which I said has can
take a very large range of values so
what we do basically is we fit a just a
decision tree of acceptance probability
verses number of answers and allows us
to bend the variable into maybe like 10
different bins so you can see here that
they're kind of the lines and the y-axis
are different bins so there's one from
one answer to maybe a hundred another
from 100 to 500 and so on which is
basically got from a decision tree and
then within each bin and we fit a
logistic regression model and we get
these reversal of trends so that's
that's how we kind of decide we get for
for continuous for continuous data seems
to work pretty well for us yeah so so
basically we disaggregate compare the
trends compare them to the original
trend
and if we find opposing behavior then we
found cases of Simpsons paradox and and
a case to say that okay maybe you've
observed a trend but actually is it just
a result of of the way the data is
aggregated and actually the trend is
different at Adam or at the more
microscopic level versus under fully
aggregated level so we've we've applied
this method to some data sets including
I told you about Stack Overflow also
some interesting ones on Khan Academy
and Joe lingo I won't talk too much
about them but they're in our papers if
you want to check that out so yeah I
just want to highlight one of our one of
our results was previously found just in
a different paper that our result kind
of picked up and just found true
traditional data analysis and kind of
you know just deep data diving into into
the data so I think this is kind of a
tool that a nots only let us like avoid
Simpsons paradox but but by actually
finding Simpsons paradox we find these
interesting patterns in our data set and
interesting kind of correlations between
features so I think it's a really useful
tool for both you know avoiding miss
conclusions and also finding like
interesting data with interesting
patterns within the data so to come back
to the earlier question yes answering
performance decreases as you as you
answer more questions and also for the
reddit one that actually users who users
become less active over time so here the
confounding variable is basically it's a
survivorship survival bias so so here
we're aggregating overall users and here
these individual lines are you know the
green one is user who've been on a
platform for four zero to one year this
is from one to two years and you can see
that within these subgroups actually use
your behavior platter sorry actually
decreases they become less interested
over time okay so now I'm going to pass
on to Nazneen is going to give a
demonstration I'm going to go through a
little example or github or do table is
available public you can use it for
decomposition part we are using C++
because it's it's pretty fast but for a
CH and reversal part we are using Python
since it has a good packages for change
analysis and plotting parts we we have
used batch escape for connecting these
two components and the output of the
algorithm is a series of PDF files for
each pair we have a PDF file with four
plots which helps you to understand
what's going on in that same sauce
paradox pair the only thing you need to
do for using the code is working with
these two files run dot as such you
basically don't need to do anything with
that you just need to run it but for
input info dot JSON you just need to
specify hyper parameters for the
algorithm the first parameter is your
data set name the second one is target
variable column which is 0 base target
variable name which is going to use for
using in plots the other one is the
number of pins which is going to use on
a pinning part for this is maximum
number of pins for each of those
conditioning variables and least number
of data points in each pin is a minimum
number of data points in each pin these
two green ones are stopping criteria for
the pinning algorithm which is using
r-squared measures which is maximizes R
Square D measures for the beans the
other two parameters are a level of
significance which is going to use for
the deviance
we are checking if whether or not or
trend is significant and after that we
are going to see the trend reversal is
significant or not the longest case is
using for the plots if you have a heavy
Hale valuable you can set the luggage
scale as true for that particular
variable so the plots looks better for
that right the output files are for five
type of output it's been said CSV that
tells you that what are the means for
each of those variables entry is number
of data points in each of the bins it's
it's correspond to bins dot CSV and y
but Y bar chi is average value of y for
each bins and our code is for binary
variables so Y bar Y bar Chi is a value
between 0 and 1 R squared improvement is
are quite improvement for each of those
variables and for each of those Simpsons
paradox pairs we have a PDF file for
example as you can see in a cycle data
we have seven different seems of spartax
pairs so we have seven different PDF
files for each of those players and for
plots for each of those pairs now I'm
going to show you a demo this is for a
github repository
I'm going to run it
this is the repository we have a sample
input here which is a part of an Academy
data set but for demo purposes I've
generated it takes time so I don't want
to bother you I generated a small
example synthetic example which only has
two variables and one outcome binary
outcome variable and the plot looks like
this this is X 1 this is X 1 and this is
y y increases as a function of X 1 but
if you condition on X 2 which are these
colors Y decreases in kind in terms of X
Y so let's run our code on this data
copy and I'll paste it as in input file
the only thing you need to do after
pasting the data here is to change this
input info to a JSON file
I want maximum number of pins to be 10
in the least number of data points to be
1 the name of target variable is y
target variable column as you see is 2
because it's 0 base I live level of
significance as 5% that CSV
CSV file name is down word binary binary
I don't want to ignore edit any color
and I don't want to use like skills I
think it's ready
now I'm going here I just need to around
this round that Sh
it's finished as you can see we have
lots of information in a lot the target
variable is y features are X 1 and X 2
we have R squared improvements here and
once it have found a trend reversal it
searches for significance of trend
reversal which is here it's significant
and it's going to write a output in our
output file we have one pair and one PDF
as you can see the trend is upward Y
increases by as function of X 1 but when
you condition on X 2 here we have
reverse trend and the other two plots
are these two this is a histogram
two-dimensional histogram of X 1 and X 2
the color is y here and as you can see
in the aggregate that version starts
from blue and goes to red but at this
disaggregated version it starts from red
and goes to blue it becomes blue and the
other outputs are here here in temporary
files we have beans that CSV maybe it's
better to show you the real data
here this is or Hanukkah part of or
Academy data for example here for all
problems the first mean start from five
and goes to to any the second win start
from two anyone goes to 47 and etc this
is bins for all of the variables and
this one is number of data points in
each of those bins to 2,000 data points
900 data points in each of those bins
this is corresponding to B instead CSV
and in this one we have average Y value
for each of those bins and our score
improvement is this one which this is
r-squared improvement for each of those
variables for example session session
noms such an index to summarize Simpsons
paradox is exist in even in your data so
you must care about it and you can use
or algorithm to find you at Simpsons
paradox in your data if you have a
binary outcome variables and our future
work is to find a more robust
statistical version of finding this
trend reversal currently we report at
pair as a simple pair of and more than
half of the subgroups have opposite sign
with the aggregated wear data but we
believe that there are more robust
statistical where chance for do this and
we already working on that and thank you
if you have any questions we will happy
to
[Applause]
yes
we got a mic over here yeah I think so
the question was if you need to look at
sub groups to determine trends yep good
question is how are you so I think I
think when dealing with human behavioral
data distributions of features and
variables are often very heavy tailed
which is to say that lots of people for
example if you look at a social network
and you look at the distribution of
connectivity lots of people have maybe
100 connections 200,000 connections but
there are some people with a million
connections and and and there they are I
guess the outliers or I mean it's
whether you call them outliers or
whether they're just you know it's a
it's a it's a tricky question of whether
it's an outlier just it's it's a it's a
fact that the distribution is heavy
tailed like that so oftentimes you can
imagine then that that outliers have
drastically different behavior than the
typical members of the population so so
I think that by decomposing into into
subgroups like that you can maybe
understand why your outliers exists
versus just maybe thinking that it's
some you know Y value that has deviated
a lot that maybe it does occur because
you know the underlying data has
distributions that are very heavy tailed
and because of them heavy tails that
Gerard is point zero zero one percent
that have these very very high data
points and that and that is what could
explain the the outliers in E or maybe
outcome variable so so I think yeah that
that breaking down underlying
distributions into subgroups especially
when dealing with heavy tail data is
always a good approach
is there a way to do you think to
generalize this approach from subgroups
you know along one covariant you know or
one confounder to like multivariate
clusters of subgroups that you know
might have to deal with interactions
between different variables yeah so you
so you may be using like multiple
confounding variables is that it
yeah like the subgroups could be you
know clusters that are different
determined by you know you know in a in
a higher dimensional space yeah sure
exactly so at the moment all confounding
variables are basically I we just like
conditioned on one variable
I guess our clusters as such are just
these like bins are these like subgroups
of that confounding variable but yeah I
guess the one of the immediate ways we
thought about generalizing it was to try
to I guess condition on multiple
covariates or multiple variables and I
guess kind of bend them so that you have
these kind of clusters I think for us
more more pressing was just maybe
getting our statistical tests down
better before actually generalizing it
to multiple dimensions and which I I
think definitely there there could be
more interaction terms there that could
be captured definitely yeah yeah we've
mean our methodology is is is you know
definitely by no means perfect but
certainly we have found it useful for
for finding may be more obvious ones or
you know ones where a kind of a clear
trend exists on that kind of
two-dimensional interaction
so it seemed like the sample size across
each sub group sometimes varied
considerably yep if you normalized or
try to sub sample so that you had equal
number of samples across the subgroups
yeah does that affect the results big
time yeah definitely so essentially you
can't get Simpsons paradox if your sub
groups are the same size yep so it's
basically an artifact of your subgroups
being it's it's essentially that's the
root cause of Simpsons paradoxes it's
kind of that your subgroups are of
different size but also dr. some
variation of the relationship of the
outcome variable within these subgroups
so if your subgroups are of differing
size but your your your response
variable it's the same across them then
you won't have a paradox um if your so
groups our difference there getaway
around two so you need differences in
subgroup population and then also the
response variable stuff exactly so yeah
so in terms of experimental design if
you just fix if you know there's gonna
be some for example a smoking one if you
just fix the distributions within each
age groups then you wouldn't have had
the paradox it's it's it's purely a
result exactly of of difference in
distributions perfect
have you considered any sort of
unsupervised methods for your clustering
so like if you just take out the target
variable and then you okay means to
create the clusters in a multivariate
fashion yep they have you tried that in
anyway no haven't tried it but
definitely if you could we're open to
you know new ways of doing it so if you
want to do a pull request submit some
clustering technique or even yeah I'll
be happy to talk more about it
afterwards I guess in general
Simpsons paradox relates to some kind of
response variable so that when it came
to Bening I guess the first thing we
thought it was yeah kind of fit a tree
and and and and just get the more
homogeneous subgroups by their
relationship with the outcome variable
which which worked pretty well
if you do even binning it doesn't work
well for you know these kind of
heterogeneous distributions but you kind
of if you can picture you need to plot
the histogram on a log scale and even
binning doesn't capture well if you do
log scale bidding that's not the perfect
solution or percent of binning either so
the decision tree approach worked really
well and right now we have it that you
kind of specify maybe the the minimum or
the maximum number of bins and a minimum
number of data points but we're going to
extend that so there's some kind of like
cross-validation where it picks the best
bins just from like a cross-validation
approach but yet we're we're definitely
open to if anybody is any ideas about
statistical testing or on supervised
spinning just definitely reach out and
happy to find ways to improve the
algorithm and hopefully some days you
guys can try it out and might be might
be useful
hi I'm just being curious that do you
guys have any cooperation with ISI yeah
soso nazaneen-e on I take this on yeah I
am PhDs you Dan that is a yes and my
supervisor my adviser is Kirsten
alderman yeah but before tada I also
worked at ISA I was sponsored by two
james s mcdonnell foundation on a
fellowship there so this is work that we
did together in is a yeah
probably thanks very much